Arakita, it's okay,
we don't hide
anything for our sake.  You know,
yes trust 4th place
People will laugh at the shore
And I trust the Sogata building Shinkan The
spectrum threatens
that trust If the bond of trust is betrayed
You're going to steal the house
Jacket
hey First of all, we're mobilizing all of our military power over there.
The movements of the shore applicants are scattered,
and it's because they couldn't even grab the elusive Spectrum ship, and
they opened it without obeying orders.  Okay,
on top of that, Mordlet, you
'll allow me to say a few words.
Well, it's
true,
I'm totally
absorbed in
it,
so I don't know if it was Bragwale who made a mistake in judgment
.
I will support him until the age
[music]
I'm sorry